[Music]
there is good reason to bring those
beverage bottles back when you're done
with them everyday glass can be recycled
over and over again without losing its
quality but only about one third of the
glass Americans use is processed in
Louisiana a couple of Tulane students
found a way to turn that trash into
treasure using it for Coastal
Restoration in a state steadily losing
its wetlands
with more than 125
000 Acres of Shoreline Lake
Pontchartrain is one of North America's
largest Gulf Coast ecosystems
fed by a delicate mix of both fresh and
saltwater wetlands
as louisianans this is our heart and
soul that balance is what Francisca
Troutman is trying to save we rely on
these Wetlands these marshes for our
livelihood but also for our protection
against storms and hurricanes as they
roll into the city
we rode along with her to the Big Branch
Coastal restoration area near Bayou
Lacombe so this is it yeah so this is
the Sands like I said it's a little
coarser than what we usually see in
these areas oh boy
okay you got it I think so to see how
burlap bags filled with crushed glass
are making a difference in the fight
against Coastal erosion it's all this
water that would normally Meander down a
bayou slowly and find its way back out
into Lake Pontchartrain has now found a
shortcut that is essentially going
straight out at a high rate of speed
into the lake
Nick Stevens is a wetland ecologist so
when the water moves this fast we don't
have any sediment deposition there's no
soils dropping out of the water and are
creating new land
a vicious cycle of Rushing Water fueled
by erosion that further blows out
vegetation already weakened by land loss
between 1932 and 2016 about 25 percent
of Louisiana's Wetlands were washed away
Troutman and a team of volunteers slowed
that process by planting bull rush
shoots fortified by those sacks of sand
so all of these bull rush plants are
what we planted in the project all new
yes so these Mounds here yeah all of
this this was all Open Water
um it's kind of insane to see now
it took just nine months we were not
expecting that project to work so well
so quickly
our marshlands are like our first line
of defense for storms so as goes this
particular Marsh so goes the land behind
the North Shore right
it all starts inside this 40 000 square
foot recycling plant in New Orleans
were mounds of bottles that would have
ended up in landfills or processed into
sand this is our mixed mountain of glass
this is where we mix all the different
colors that we get so especially for our
pickup clients like restaurants and bars
Troutman co-founded glass half full with
her partner Max Stites after a light
bulb moment over a bottle of wine it was
his idea really but I claimed the name
it's been a while to ride for sure from
you know a bottle of wine to millions of
bottles of wine launched three years ago
on GoFundMe
the company went from a backyard
operation to recycling more than three
million pounds of glass step one is
consumption you know this is someone and
hopefully someone enjoys it from there
can either be picked up by our team or
dropped off at our facility from there
it goes into our processing system
putting into a giant Glass Mountain
we'll come in with a front-end motor
scoop it up put into our processing
Machinery which will start that
pulverization process
from there we refine it and sift it into
various sizes each with a different
utilization or you know different
purpose and then from there it's you
know bagged packaged and you know ready
to go be deployed to something that
actually you know benefits our community
over and over again take me to your best
friend's house they got their message
out through social media the funny thing
is he made one on the glass half full
Tick Tock I think it got 9.5 million
views
but then I made one of my Tick Tock and
got 14 million
I think it was one for this really
dramatic music where I went like
I just like made these faces and I put
text on screen like I couldn't believe
my state didn't recycle glass
so now we're using it for Coastal
restoration it's always the same like
idea that goes viral Troutman and steitz
hope to spread the message far and wide
do you see the scaling Beyond New
Orleans absolutely our long-term goals
in the next few years be the glass
recycler for this Gulf South Region so
including Mississippi and south
Louisiana that's another thing with our
Generations we're seeing firsthand that
climate change is not hundreds of years
away or decades away it is happening now
we see in Louisiana most recently with
hurricane Ida huge huge portions of land
that are washed away state says true
recycling turning old glass bottles into
new ones just hasn't worked and the fact
of the matter is you know these smelting
facilities to you know these bottling
producers they're they're not that many
in the U.S
they're extremely expensive to build
they're very very energy intensive and
so that's why we always say you know it
might not be the perfect solution in
everyone's eyes but at least it's a
solution in which the glass is no longer
going to the landfill but actually doing
something good could you
see Louisiana being restored to what it
was 25 50 100 years ago I mean it's
definitely an uphill battle restoring
our coastline
and I think the main goal is to stop any
more loss and just prevent as much as we
can and protect the coastlines that we
do have
[Music]
and another great reason this is such a
great idea is that we're facing a global
sand shortage sand is the second most
utilized consumed raw material behind
water and we're using it like two to
three times more higher rate than we had
some 20 years ago so you know it's
important for us to one help to
replenish a natural resource to to make
sure you Shore up Coastal erosion but
three
recycling matters well it's interesting
they say that in the piece that true
recycling has they think hasn't worked
right so you find some modification for
it that does work that's a win-win for
everyone yeah and it's amazing how
quickly they were able to have an impact
there because that map yeah that you
showed Oh yeah is frightening it really
is we we see maps of Louisiana from 50
years ago the boot no longer exists yeah
if they can help rebuild some of that
somehow some way
it's amazing